what's up gq this is trax and today
we're going to be breaking down the
biggest pieces in a little uzi verts
jewelry collection
so by far the biggest jewelry move
of my lifetime is little uzi
vert putting a pink diamond in his
forehead he took them one of the most
expensive diamonds
in the jewelry game for hip-hop or
otherwise and put it right smack in the
middle of his forehead
so let me mention as a jeweler some pros
and cons of having a stone like this
right
someone who's looking at that stone of
the corner of their eye that's their
meal ticket
they get their hands on that stone you
just have a target on your forehead
you know that's dangerous you can't put
that down you can't take a break you
can't go to the store you got
millions of dollars literally on your
head you know maybe when you're on the
red carpet you have your stone on your
head and you're looking you're the
center of attention i don't care
if it's robert de niro on your left side
and jay-z on your right
they're gonna look at your forehead and
they're gonna think wow
whether they like to admit it or not but
then when you're somewhere else doing
something else
that's a major con you don't want to you
want to be able to put the jewelry down
and i think that's probably what was
across his mind when he had the stone
removed the pro is
you look like a millionaire the con is
you look like a millionaire the other
major problem
uh the major con with this piece is the
setting has claws on it so what really
is going on with the setting how does it
implant
you have to have a jeweler and a surgeon
to really make this happen properly now
what i'm assuming what happened was it's
just some sort of way to set this in
that it goes under the skin and then the
skin heals around it
and then it's kind of set inside but the
claws get
stuck on fibers and it could pull on the
stone coming out of your head but the
concept is ridiculous
and if he gets the right plastic surgeon
and the right setting i think it would
be even crazier
the thing about little uzi verts setup
over here is it's very mature
and starting with that cross in fancy
yellow with the fancy yellow chain
that's around there that particular
cross consists of six
large diamonds at least two and a half
character three carat per stone fancy
yellow
they seem to be asher cut which is
essentially an emerald cut that's a
square i love asher
i think that's what he has over there it
looks phenomenal
he's got teardrop earrings with these
beautiful pear-shaped pink diamonds
there right they're more of a
more or less on the lady side of a
jewelry style but he pulls it off
magnificently well
you're not looking at somebody and
thinking that that jewelry is misplaced
you're looking at somebody that's doing
it on another level there's another
under his eleonte piece that he's
wearing he's got that
another big pink diamond over there he's
he's doing big rocks this guy
when i see it as a jeweler i see
somebody who knows
how to spend their money and when i see
it you know i see somebody who's smart
to be honest with you because he has
pieces that make a statement that the
queen of england
will take a second glance at you know
what i'm saying so that's
kudos to him so here you have a little
bit of the classic hip-hop style with
the two rings
you know fully iced and so on and so
forth the pave
smaller stones slightly larger stones a
beautiful platinum rolex on the wrist
but then
on the other wrist he goes back to the
elite
jewelry style fancy intense yellow
diamonds
in a variety of different settings a
completely different look
now what little uzi vert should know
about fancy intense yellow diamonds or
what anybody should know about fancy
intense yellow diamonds is they're hard
to price
because you could get them cheaper you
could find them this way it's not
h color g color eye color d color it's
fancy yellow fancy intense yellow so it
gives the opportunity for jeweler to
make more money is that what eliante did
i doubt it i doubt that he would want to
play with a guy like a little uzi vert
but this is a lot of money to put into
diamonds and you definitely want to get
the right value out of these pieces
i doubt that little uzi is overlooking
any any aspect like that but
his jewelry collection really speaks to
who he is
he's a complete unique individual he's a
serious guy
so here little uzi's got the classic set
up you know cubans
big eye style pieces with three pointer
four pointer
vs stones covering gold but then on the
other hand
he has a cross there with roses this is
a beautiful cross
it's a custom piece but anybody would
love to have a piece like that and it's
almost like a rosary
with big rose gold beads and when you're
doing that you don't have to
ice out every bead you could let them
rock out of all those pieces sure
you could be you know desperate for
attention some might say with a fully
iced out cubans and so on and so forth
but not with that rosary you're an
artist and he is
he's proven that with every piece of
jewelry he does
this is a little uzi vert superstar look
right here when you're on that concert
you want to have all of the diamond
chains on the lights are on you it
doesn't matter if you're in the
nosebleed seats those diamonds are
hitting you putting your sunglasses
on i don't care how dark it is or
whatever it is because those diamonds
are hidden
now this is more of the classic
superstar he's got the marilyn manson
piece
which he's paying homage to artists it's
definitely fly
and you know he's got that uh ridiculous
cross piece as well i mean listen he's a
monster this is a monster setup you know
he's either making more money or
spending more money than
other rappers on jewelry it's either one
or the other right because
there's a lot of carrots here here's a
closer look at this beautiful spike
chain
very nice craftsmanship on that
beautiful links it's very difficult to
ice out links all the way around
because where are you going to cut the
chain where you're going to assemble it
to headache because you can't just flip
licks around put a diamond in you have
to put it in shellac take it out put it
in take it out put it in but you do it
when a guy's spending millions of
dollars you make sure that he gets what
he wants how he wants but this is not
the project you want to come across
when you get that call i sent out a
cuban or a puffy gucci link is no
problem
that is a different story if you take a
look at the puffy gucci link
you see the links in between is a simple
gold link that claps it that's not a
headache to do you ice out the links
individually
then you clasp them done deal and you're
happy and you're fine but now
when you're gonna do in our iced out
points all the way around you set this
side nice set that side
i don't want to be the jeweler working
on that but the the budget was there
and then you have this uh massive uh
cuban very thick cuban and then that
bracelet is something different
something completely different and these
are high gold weight high carrot
high dollar amount not playing around
so first 25th birthday little uzi vert
another iconic look i mean
pink diamonds in the ears dripping down
iced out cuban rosary fully iced out
pieces
a ridiculous ring right there his setup
over here is he's iconic with the
fashion right
the jacket and the rhinestones it kind
of blends in
to the ice on the neck and the infinity
link and the pointers
he has so many different looks it's kind
of crazy to be able to
quantify that but he's fully iced out
the disc-like around pieces that he's
wearing the smaller one is nothing crazy
uh excluding the chain
forty thousand fifty thousand dollars
the larger one
sixty seventy thousand dollars around
there the chains
forty thousand fifty thousand on those
and those are prices you know listen if
one guy's buying one chain for forty
thousand dollars that's cool but if
you're spending a half a million dollars
a million dollars
you should deserve a little bit of a
discount i'm trying to you know paint
that picture when you're spending that
type of money on that piece
because come on a guy's gonna give you a
million dollars
how much do you spend on material you
spend half a million dollars on the
materials on the golden diamonds and
take a half a million dollars put in
your pocket
is that fair little uzi vert i don't
know
i wouldn't do that personally and i
doubt that eliante is doing that because
these guys are coming back to them
what's up how you doing what you doing
talking about some jewelry
okay that's new see you later
so here little uzi vert i mean he's got
a lot of different jewelry looks
i mean he keeps surprising me one thing
he did here is he has
upside down but get cross it's not the
most expensive cross in the world
but he had it modified to be upside down
it screams that pump mixed with hip hop
uh
look sick piece not very expensive
attainable but the chain that it's on
not too cheap all right that's a that's
a serious chain more pointers
cubans on the ysl are amazing as well
you could say at least forty thousand
dollars of pop for those
and uh the the two wire cells one is
indented one is embossed
so they kind of have like this mirror
version so to speak of one another
that's something that i noticed on that
piece that i think is pretty cool
because they're the same piece
yet they're kind of the opposite very
nice set up on stage rocking out
punk hip-hop mixed together fully iced
hundreds of thousands of dollars
rolly on the wrist and then there's
something on a choker there that has
that script
font that is you know just another touch
for a superstar to have
chanel pieces more rolexes for him
on stage this was obviously an outfit
change that he put on something
different something subtle
things like this you know locks and and
things like
it's things that you could do or you
would see somebody making
in high school right you know like the
punk kid and then you know
it becomes high fashion when you
recreate it in gold diamonds especially
when chanel is doing it
the rolex is a classic rolex looks like
a datejust that's fully iced
but the chanel pieces is classic
little uzi vert classic superstar
jewelry
again right puffy gucci link fully iced
the rappers
love that got a classic fully iced piece
on it that's not his most
ridiculous iconic look but he's got them
all he's got the classic superstar
he's got some feminine the chanel with
pink diamonds
big pointers and then you know a little
uzi where he doesn't stop
this guy he'll ice out a chain for his
wallet
a chain for his belt his mind is
completely out of the box he's never
been in the box for more than 10 seconds
when it comes to jewelry
[Music]
so uzi's collection is really impressive
to me as a jeweler what do you got
pink diamonds chanel hip-hop pieces
iconic pieces different links cubans
chains pointers
but of course what takes the cake is to
be brave enough to not
care what anybody thinks at all and put
massive pink diamonds in your forehead
and in your chain and in your ears
you know he set a trend that pushed the
envelope of the jewelry industry
he brought attention to the jewelry
industry brought attention to pink
diamonds another
rapper that's bringing vast amounts of
capital
in to the jewelry industry by setting
trends that needs to be
acknowledged people are buying ice style
watches in china
in southeast asia all over the world
based upon
these guys that are either from atlanta
or south side chicago and the trends
that they set
plain and simple and i have to study his
jewelry collection
to be a better jeweler that should say
something